we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p no hate
today just two heartwarming wholesome
messages of support I wasn't I'm just
calling because I want to tell you to
keep up the good work I watched your
show and you're one of the few people
that I think actually reports honestly
so keep it up by all means alright and
another wholesome message independent
media and streaming it for us so we can
know the truth and the whole world can
see it
good job thank you thank you so much all
right you you guys know how much hate we
get in the voicemail so just to uh to
completely wholesome callers today no
trolling no anti-semitism no homophobia
no use of a variety of four-letter words
no grammar mistakes it's a beautiful
thing we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about the tragic
death of kobe bryant and we will
contextualise it as well plus much more
that's really a huge story over the last
24 hours we will talk about other things
become a member to get instant access to
the bonus show at join pakman.com and by
becoming a $5 a month or greater member
at patreon.com slash david pakman show